- Hello Believe Nation, I
started the Mentor Me series
with the goal to try to hang
around people who've done
a lot more than us and by
sticking with them a little
bit longer, hopefully some of
their ideas, their strategy
their mindsets, their
beliefs seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves,
so today we're going to
learn from Tony Robbins
and examine some of his
best motivational clips
that he posted in 2016 as
an incentive for you to go
for your best this year.
Mentor me, Tony.
Clip number one is my
personal favorite, and
as always guys as Tony's
talking if he says something
that really really resonates
with you, please leave
in the comments below, put
quotes around it so that
other people can be
inspired as well, enjoy.
- The number one thing that's
going to change your life,
the only thing, that
will change your life,
change your business, change
your money, change your
relationship, is you
must raise your standard.
And I know that sounds
boring, stupid, basic,
but it's the truth.
The only thing that
changes our life long term,
is when we raise our standards.
What does that mean, that
sounds so boring and dumb.
It means that all of us in
life have things we want.
We don't get what we want,
we get what we have to have.
Remember what I said earlier?
We all get what we tolerate,
in ourselves and other people.
But when you're no longer
willing to tolerate something,
that's when your life changes.
The difference in people
is their standards.
Period.
The difference in people
is their standards, period.
And what do I mean by standards?
Everyone in the world
has a list of things they
think they should do.
I should lose weight.
I should work out.
I should spend more time with my kids.
I should work harder.
I should make more calls.
I should, I should, I should, I should.
And then you know what,
people don't do their shoulds
and they get mad at themselves
and they, what I call
should all over themselves,
they beat themselves up
about it, what changes
people is when your should
becomes a must.
When suddenly the thing
you said should happen,
has to happen.
That's when human beings change.
It's like if you want to take the island
and you're the head of
the army and you want to
take the island, the most
powerful way to take the island
is to burn the boats.
Cause if there's no way
to go back, it's amazing
what happens when it's a
must to do something versus
a should, that's what
makes human beings succeed.
There is another level,
the only reason you keep
saying there isn't is you
feel so exhausted about
where you are, but life,
the universe or God is
just testing you because
there is another level.
If this is good, giant jump
to excellence, start good,
poor, to good to excellence.
There's a level where all
your dreams are realized.
There's a level that you've
always dreamed about,
it is real it has not gone away.
But it takes that extra
burst when you think there's
nothing left there's no
way, you've tried everything
ten million times and you keep going.
It's almost like God is
saying if you keep hitting
this wall enough times I will
see that you will not stop
that you are filled with
that level of determination,
faith and courage and then
the door opens and you
get to that next level but
most people don't know is,
the next level is just
two millimeters above,
and it's called outstanding
ladies and gentlemen!
Outstanding!
(crowd cheers)
What's it called?
- [Crowd] Outstanding!
- What's it called?
- Outstanding!
Magnificent!
Unstoppable!
Extraordinary!
Not excellent, it's a different level.
It's a level where you
are not one of the best,
you are the best.
And you know what's amazing?
You only have to be two
millimeters more than everybody
else and you get everything.
You get the joy, the
laughter, the fun, the family
the passion, the economics,
the freedom, the spirit,
it's all there.
What Jerry McGuire called the quan, baby.
All of it, and it's just two
millimeters above and most
excellent people give up
because they're exhausted
and there's some people
that go the harder I hit it,
the more I hit it, sooner
or later it's going down.
I'm not stopping and
when you do that enough,
it pops open.
What makes you a leader is your
ability to make a decision,
who's with me on this, right?
And anybody can make the easy decision.
Right, so what makes you a
leader is you can make the
tough decisions and what
makes you leader is, you make
the decision, what makes you
a great leader is you know
I may be wrong, but if I have
to wait till everything's
resolved, nothing's going to get resolved.
So I'll make a decision,
if I make a decision
and it's wrong I'll find
out quicker than if I sit
on the fence while my life goes by.
I remember I have shared
this with maybe a few of you
before but years and years
ago when we had the big
Gulf War, General Norman
Schwartzkopf's a friend of mine
and passed away a few years
ago, and I used to bring
him in to talk about leadership.
And one of the first times
I ever asked him, I said
how do you define leadership?
How do you know when a person's
a real leader and he said
when they can make decisions.
I can remember when I was,
he was an assistant to a
general and I forget what
the exact position is
and he said he was responsible
for reading all the briefs
and this general is one of the
highest generals in the army
and there was a decision
that needed to be made and it
had to do with ten years of
going back and forth with
the Pentagon, trying to
figure out if they're going to
go one direction or another,
it was a gigantic decision
that was going to effect the
way the army was structured,
how money was going to be divided,
what resources are going to
go where, and he said they
brought in this group of
20 people and they had
this two hour meeting and
everybody got up and pitched
their side of what they
thought was right.
And at the end when it
was completely done, the
general said has everyone
said their piece?
They said yes, he said do this.
It was plan A or plan B
or whatever it was out of
the three choices that they had.
And everybody said okay,
general, saluted him and
ran off to go implement this thing.
And Schwartzkopf said he was
freaking out because he knew
there was no way that general
could have read everything
even he'd read, and this was
such a complex piece, and there
was only two hours and
everybody gave their best, but
oh my god there's so
many things to consider,
and so he finally got up
enough courage he said
to go to the general, and
said general, permission to
speak freely?
He said at ease, speak freely.
He said general there is
so much information here,
there's so much here no one's
going to really know for sure.
How the hell could you just
make that decision like that?
He said because someone had to make it.
He said because it's been
going around for 10 years
back and forth and no one
being able to make a decision.
He said what if you're wrong?
He said if I'm wrong,
we'll find out quicker.
If I'm right the job will be done.
Next question, right?
It's like when you're put
in charge, take command.
Everyone in this room knows how to create.
You're not a manager of your
life, you're a creator of your
life or you wouldn't be in this room.
How do you create your life?
You get hungry for something, don't you?
Who has done something in
your life that once seemed
difficult or impossible and
now it's part of your life?
Who's got something in your
life in this area, say I?
- [Crowd] I!
- How did you do it?
You created it, three ways.
Number one, you decided there's
something you wanted so bad
that you unleashed all of
your desire, you became
obsessed with it.
If it was a business or a
car or a relationship or
transformation in your body.
If there's something you once
envisioned and now it's real
it's because you didn't
just envision it, you
brought so much emotion to it
that now it's in your life.
It was once a dream it was once
a goal and now it's in your
life, how many have something
like that in your life now?
Say I.
- [Crowd] I!
- You may take it for
granted now, hopefully not,
but it was once just a vision.
It may have seemed impossible at one time.
So how did you do it?
You started with a concrete
vision of what you wanted
and you focused on it
continuously didn't you?
Wherever focus goes, energy?
- [Crowd] Flows
- Flows.
You envision something,
you got clear about it
and then you started thinking
about all the reasons
why you wanted it.
You got excited about it.
You said this is what's next for me now.
I want this, you may
have dreamed about it,
thought about it, talked
about it, but when you
focus on something continuously,
something magical happens.
You get insights, don't you?
You overhear a conversation,
and you hear something
you wouldn't have heard if
you didn't have that outcome
or goal that you wanted so badly.
Whosever come up with
something obsessed about it,
didn't even know how to
do it and just happened
and it came together, who's
had that experience, say I?
- [Crowd] I!
- So why don't we tap into
that power now for your
business and life.
There was a day that I became wealthy.
I will tell you the day, I
know that day I was rich.
I was broke, I was pissed, I
was angry at everybody else
but who?
Myself.
But really underneath
it I was mad at myself.
I just couldn't beat myself
up anymore so I was pissed
and I had a friend that I
loaned money to when I had
barely enough and I knew he
needed it and I gave him $1200
and I'm here not able to eat,
I'm down to like 25, $26 and
I'm calling him and he's
not returning my call and I
just need some money and he's
ignoring me, I didn't ignore
him, so I'm pissed, I'm frustrated.
In the midst of all
this, I'm also pragmatic.
I got 25 and change, call it $26.
What the hell am I going to do?
I don't have any plans for
economics, I got overhead that's
crazy, I'm living in this
little tiny apartment 400
square feet in Venice, California.
So I thought okay, when I
was totally broke early on
when I was 17 I used to
save my money up, and go to
the smorgasbord and load
up for Christmas, you know
load up for the week, so
I said I was in Venice,
I'm going to go over to Marina
del Rey, where all the yachts
are and there's this place
there called El Chorito
and I'm going to go they have
an all you can eat smorgasbord
and I'm going to load up for the winter.
I'm going to get that.
So I didn't drive there, cause
I wasn't going to spend the
gas to get there, plus I needed
the walk so I walked there.
And I go in, I'm not
dressed really great, but
it's Marina del Rey, it's
okay and I got a place right
by the window and I can
see these yachts going by
and I'm dreaming of what
life could be like and I'm
starting to let go of my anger
and I'm starting to focus
on what I want instead
of what I don't want.
How many follow, say I?
- [Crowd] I.
- And that shifted me just a bit,
and now I'm eating which shifted me a lot.
And I got this giant plate
stacked up, and I don't know
what the amount was it was
like $6.95, $7.95 right?
So I'm going to do this I
can probably do this three
or four times, right?
Somewhere in that range.
As I'm finishing my meal,
this little boy comes in
dressed in a little suit now
I honestly don't know how
old he'd be probably in
the third grade, so maybe
eight years old, nine years
old something like that.
And he was so adorable and
he opened the door for his
mother, and his mother's an
attractive lady and he came over
and he pulled out the seat
for her and she sat down.
And she was a pretty lady
but, as pretty as she was
I was totally obsessed by this boy.
He was just, he had presence
at seven or eight years old.
And it moved me.
I don't know why it just moved me.
And I thought this kid is like pure,
I want him to always be
this way, he's a good kid,
he's a giver so I got up
and I paid for the meal,
and whatever it was six, seven bucks.
So now I've got whatever
left, 17, 18, 19 dollars.
And I walk up to this little
boy and I said excuse me?
And I said I just want to
acknowledge you for being
such an extraordinary gentleman.
I said I saw the way you
treated your lady, I saw how
you opened the door, how
you pulled the chair out,
I said that's class.
I said my name's Tony, what's yours?
I don't honestly remember his
name, Charlie or something.
And he looked up at me and I
said Charlie, that's amazing,
taking your date out
for a lunch like this.
He goes, "well actually, she's my mom"
(crowd laughs)
And I said that's even more cool.
And he said oh, but I'm not
just taking her to lunch
I'm just I think he said he was eight.
I said oh yes you are, and
I had no plan for this,
I just reached in my
pocket, I took all the money
I had left, 17, 18, 19 dollars
and I put it on the table
and I said you're taking her to lunch.
He looked up at me and he
goes "I can't take that"
I said sure you can!
He said "why?"
Because I'm bigger than you are.
(crowd laughs)
and he smiled real big and I
didn't even look at his mom.
I just turned and walked
away and I didn't walk out of
that door, I (bleep) flew home.
I should have been freaking out.
How the (bleep) am I going to eat?
But I didn't, I (bleep) flew
because something inside of me
had finally got past
scarcity, had finally realized
there's something inside
of us more than our limits,
especially around this
(bleep) thing called money.
That I had let terrorize me.
I got home and the mailman
came that day and I had no idea
how I was going to have my next meal.
And a (bleep) letter comes
and it's from the guy
I loaned the money to.
Handwritten note saying I've
been avoiding you, it's wrong
I'm so sorry, you were there
when I needed you, here's what
I owe you plus a little bit more.
And the 1200 was there plus
another hundred for the time
that I had to take care of it.
And for me $1,300 that was
enough to run my show for
a month or two.
And I cried, and then I
decided what does this mean.
And I thought this means
that whenever you give,
it's always going to come
back, so you don't have to ever
think about that (bleep)
again, just (bleep) give.
And the rewards will be greater
than you could ever imagine.
I don't know if that's coincidence,
but I decided to believe
that day was the blessing
when I became rich,
and I can tell you honestly
I've had tough days in my life
economically, emotionally, like all of us.
But I have never gone back
to that (bleep) scarcity,
I never will.
The secret to living is giving.
Do it when you don't have
it and I promise you,
scarcity will leave your life.
Steve's a good friend of
mine and when he was building
the Wyn, I'd never forget, he
was at my home in Sun Valley,
I had just gotten to meet
him, it was New Year's and
everybody else is standing
watching the fireworks and I
was sitting at the table
and I was basically doing
my brain notes, sucking out
of his brain, everything
I possibly could, how
do you think about this,
what do you, how do you market?
And here's what I learned from Steve,
people don't buy products,
they buy feelings.
People don't buy
products, they buy states.
People don't buy products,
they buy identities.
And he and I went back
and forth for about two
and a half to three hours
and became lifelong friends
for the last decade and a half.
He came to this seminar,
sat in the front row
and I'm not, there's almost
nothing that makes me
uncomfortable, but I'm like,
what am I going to teach him?
But he sat in this event,
and at lunch took me to lunch
he goes, this is the most
valuable session I've been in
the last 10 years, I know
what I'm going to do,
this was in 2008.
He said here's what I'm going
to do, I'm going to when
all my competitors are shrinking
right now, because they're
trying to survive, I am
going to go build this giant
beach club that goes
right to Las Vegas Avenue.
I'm going to build this new entrance,
I'm going to up my services.
He said I'm going to do
what you teach, what is the
fundamental success to becoming wealthy?
It's only one thing, if
you want to be wealthy, you
have to do more for your clients than who?
[Crowd] (murmurs)
- Than anyone else, you
have to add more what?
- [Crowd] Value.
- That is the entire secret
to wealth in business.
You want it on sentence, it's simple.
Do more for others than
anyone else is doing,
add more value and you
will own them and you will
own the marketplace.
He goes you know what
I'm going to do Tony?
When everybody else is shrinking,
I'm going to add more value
so all the high end people are
going to see I'm doing more
they're going to come to
me and this down period
is going to be the most important
period of my entire career.
Because when the economy
comes back and those guys
start giving services, I'll
already own these people
they're not going to
leave me, I'm their home.
You got to ask yourself
what'll I do to add more value
and many of you think adding
more value means cutting
your prices or doing
something of that nature.
Sometimes adding value
is raising your price.
It's crazy, raising your
price can increase your sales
if it's the right piece.
Now if you raise your price
and do more, no question
that could be the right
thing in some cases.
Some of you, your market
is the cheapest price.
Maybe it's time to change
that business model
because unless you're
Walmart or Amazon or somebody
that can do things in massive
volume and lose money and
sustain it, you might need
a thing called a margin.
If you're going to be
successful in business, you want
a high margin.
High margins come from
high human needs being met.
The only way to deal with fear
that I've found in my life
is a couple of ways.
One of those ways is to turn it on itself
and ask yourself what am I afraid of?
I'm afraid of that?
I got to be more afraid of
what I'm going to miss out on.
Missing out on my mission,
missing on who I'm supposed
to be, missing, in other
words, if you're not going to
get rid of fear then use fear.
Use fear or it uses you, it's that simple.
So you got to say, okay what's
the price if I stay doing this
what's the price?
I need to really get scared
if I learn all this and
I don't follow through, that's
something to be scared about.
And that fear will get you
over your fear, it will
push you through, turn fear onto itself.
Second way you can do it is
you've probably heard me say it
because I've used it since
I was 17, is my little
rocking chair test, right?
I'm going to sit myself in my
rocking chair, and I'm 85 years
old looking back on my life
and I say I didn't do this,
or I did.
I'm going to talk about the art
of fulfillment, what I explain
to people always is I didn't
say science of fulfillment.
Why not?
Cause it's different for
everyone, just like art.
What one person thinks is
beautiful, somebody else
might think is ugly.
So if you want to know
what's beautiful as many
people as there are on earth,
it's an art 'cause everyone
has a different view.
If you want to know what God
loves, the universe loves,
go to the forest and see it,
it's called massive diversity.
It isn't a science, it's an art.
But that art unmastered,
will create an ugly life.
An ugly life.
And the phrase I use most
often that I hope you've heard
me saying you take it in
once again maybe deeper is,
success without fulfillment
is the ultimate failure.
Success without fulfillment
But if we don't physically
make a decision on how
we're going to live, then we'll
show up like everybody else
because the human mind is
not going to make you happy.
This brain of yours won't do
it, you have to direct it.
And there's no worse fate
than to achieve everything
and not be fulfilled.
How many have had the days
where you achieve this
huge goal and your brain always
wanted it, and you got it
and then your brain went
"is this all there is?"
Who's been there?
It's the worst experience,
it's worse than failing,
isn't it?
Cause most of you are achievers
so failure never stops you
you just look at it as a
little bump in the road,
I'll try something what?
- [Crowd] Else.
- But when you succeed and
you fail, when you succeed
and you're not fulfilled,
that's scary (bleep).
If you find your passion you're
going to have this tremendous
energy, this sustainable energy.
But momentum requires you
always do the next thing
to keep the momentum going.
And the reason you get
yourself in a passionate place
is so that you change your
life, and the only thing
that changes your life
is making a decision.
So while you're in this
passionate state, that's where
you make decisions.
You don't make decisions when you're like,
(sigh) I don't know what do you think?
Alright let's decide.
If you make a decision in
a state without momentum,
if you make a decision
from a place where there's
no passion, you are not
going to get momentum,
it will kill momentum, it's
decide, commit and resolve.
Some of you in the past
you've gotten momentum,
you've gotten passionate,
you've even made a decision
but a decision is the first step.
Decision is like a war,
I got to do this, or that
alright I'm going to make myself do this.
But commitment is when you
nail after you've decided
you've committed to do
this for the long term,
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter.
You're doing this.
It takes it from this moment
and it carries it to the future
even when things are difficult.
And the third state is resolve.
Resolve means it's done.
It's like, it doesn't even
if you took action, it's
done inside you so it's done out there.
There's no question whatsoever.
Then once you decide, the
only way the commitment and
the energy and the momentum
continues is if you take
immediate, massive what my friends?
Write down in your notes,
massive action is the cure all.
Massive action is the cure all.
If you're having a difficult
time with something,
your relationship isn't
where you want it to be,
your finances are not
where you want to be,
your body's not where you want to be,
your business is not where you want to be.
You need to take massive action!
And if that doesn't
work, try something else
if that doesn't work, try something else.
Keep going with massive action
and you will find the way
because it will give you momentum.
Here's the belief I'd like you to try on.
I don't need an excuse to feel good.
What if I don't need an excuse
to feel good, I just feel
good for no good reason, how
many like this idea, say I!
(crowd cheering)
Now notice, notice when
I first said it you guys
were kind of quiet processing
it like, I don't need
to use a reason to feel good?
How will I know to feel good?
Most people don't need
a reason to feel bad.
How's it going?
Feel like crap.
How come?
Woke up.
(laughter)
In a moment, I'd like you to
celebrate for no good reason
just because you decided to
but I mean really celebrate
so you're going to rise up, are you ready?
- [Crowd] Yeah!
- We'll clap when I
yell three we go crazy,
one,
two,
three, go!
(crowd cheering enthusiastically)
Come on!
(energetic music)
- Thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video,
it's kind of impossible
not to take something,
so what did you take from
this video that you're going
to immediately apply to your
life or to your business,
please leave it down in the
comments below, I'm super
curious to find out, I
also want to give a quick
shout out to Jmiah Expose,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my
book, Your One Word, I guess
the e-book version of it,
I really really really
appreciate it and hope
you are enjoying it.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in your
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.